Les classiques résumés avant de rentrer dans ce qu'il y a de nouveau,
mais avec une concision que j'espère pouvoir exercer.
Donc la doctrine de la providence, dans l'ordre,
écriture, doctrine sur Dieu, création, pardon, décret, création, providence.
Les décrets, c'est les plans A des dieux.
La création, c'est Dieu qui mène à existence ce qui n'existait pas.
Et la providence, c'est ce qui va déterminer les mentions de ce que Dieu a créé.
Et c'est ce qui va mener à terme ce que Dieu a planifié.
C'est clair pour vous ?
Dieu a un plan A, il va l'accomplir parfaitement.
Il l'accomplira à travers la réalité du développement, quelque part libre de l'histoire,
par l'agence libre de tous ces éléments variables que nous voyons dans l'univers,
toutes les variabilités de cet univers qui est en mouvement,
auquel nous sommes susceptibles à ces variations.
toutes ces variétés auxquelles nos corps fragiles sont exposés,
dans son fonctionnement et tout son système interne,
dans la variabilité aussi, ou dans la variété tout simplement,
de nos oscillations émotionnelles,
du développement même de nos réflexions, de nos pensées,
du fonctionnement logique, de nos facultés pour fonctionner.
Donc Dieu, il est en train de soutenir tous ces fonctionnements,
mais non seulement de soutenir,
il est en train de les gouverner
de manière à conduire toutes les choses
à offens,
qui lui-même a déterminé
de la manière la plus parfaite qui est possible.
Et donc,
la Providence, elle est considérée
dans cette place, dans l'ordre,
et nous voyons par elle,
ou nous comprenons par elle,
en faisant la distinction avec les décrets.
Les décrets, c'est les plans des dieux.
La Providence, c'est la manière par laquelle
Dieu va mener à terme.
Dans la racine du mot Providence,
il y a une notion des pré-vidéos,
ou pré-visieux.
Donc c'est un dieu qui voit les choses en avance,
mais nous ne pouvons pas confondre ça
avec la doctrine de la pré-science des dieux,
la tribu divan,
d'avoir la capacité de voir en avance.
La capacité des dieux de voir en avance
est liée quelque part à la Providence
et surtout liée au décret éternel.
Donc Dieu a tout planifié et décrété parfaitement,
voilà pourquoi il sait
que toutes les choses se passeront comme il veut.
Mais toutes les choses se passeront comme il veut,
car il est tout puissant et souverain,
c'est-à-dire car par la Providence,
Dieu va être en train de contrôler
toutes les choses
et maintenir rien que l'existence
et les bons fonctionnements de toutes les choses.
Donc création a à voir avec,
mener à l'existence ce qui n'existait pas,
Providence a aussi à voir
avec les maintiens des choses que Dieu a créées.
Donc la Providence, c'est quelque part
l'activité continuelle des dieux,
l'activité des dieux en continu.
Ce n'est pas un dieu qui a donné les cordes
dans l'horloge,
une machine fermée, complète,
et qui va fonctionner de soi-même
par sa propre énergie.
Donc c'est Dieu qui soutient,
c'est en lui que nous avons les mouvements et l'être.
Et donc,
quand on considère cette doctrine,
on doit se rappeler
des difficultés qu'elle amène dès le départ.
On va traiter les difficultés plus tard
avec plus d'attention,
mais dès le départ,
on doit savoir et connaître
qu'il s'agit d'une doctrine impénétrable,
car la Bible nous donne toute l'assurance au monde
que Dieu est au contrôle
de toutes les circonstances
pour les biens de son peuple
et en accord avec sa sainteté
et sa bonté,
sauf que nous n'avons pas la capacité
à chaque instant
d'harmoniser un épisode
avec la sainteté des dieux
et la sagesse des dieux
d'avoir décrété,
d'avoir gouverné les choses
pour qu'en traversant cette étape,
il apporte les biens
qu'il a déterminés d'apporter
à travers chaque étape.
Donc on doit savoir et connaître
aussi la difficulté d'harmoniser,
par exemple,
la souveraineté des dieux absolue
dans tout ce qui se passe
et en même temps
d'affirmer,
tel que la Bible affirme,
la liberté des agents libres,
la responsabilité des agents libres
et même,
on pourrait dire,
l'aspect apparemment aléatoire
avec lequel les phénomènes,
même naturels,
sont en train de se passer dans les mondes.
Donc la doctrine,
elle est remplie des difficultés
et c'est une doctrine
révélée clairement dans la parole des dieux,
affirmée clairement dans la parole des dieux
et c'est une doctrine qui va confronter
quelques positions,
soit athéistes,
vis-à-vis au rapport
entre un dieu créateur
et sa création.
D'accord ?
Donc on a déjà traité ces distinctions,
donc nous n'affirmons pas
les panthéismes
où Dieu est intermêlé
avec la création
et quelque part la création
peut affecter la volonté des dieux.
Nous participons
même activement
de ce que Dieu est en train de faire
car nous sommes intermêlés
avec Dieu
et notre pensée positive
ou je ne sais pas comment
nos vibrations
ou notre harmonie
avec les dieux
dont nous sommes en partie,
on va changer les cours
sous de l'histoire, etc.
Ce n'est pas ça.
Donc Dieu,
même si toutes les choses
subsistent en lui,
Dieu est séparé de sa création
et lui-même
est en train de gouverner les choses
selon sa volonté
et non selon la nôtre.
Et donc,
c'est une doctrine
qui est clairement biblique.
Donc on a vu
que c'est une doctrine
qui se présente
par plusieurs aspects
évidemment clairs
dans la Bible.
Donc on peut parler
par exemple
les déclarations ouvertes
de la Bible
pour dire que Dieu
est en contrôle
de toutes les circonstances.
On a vu plusieurs passages
à propos de ça
et nous voyons aussi
que l'accomplissement
des prophéties,
les miracles enregistrés
dans la Bible
et réponse aux prières
sont des évidences
de cette relation
continue des dieux
avec la création
qui démontre
que Dieu est là
non seulement en train
de maintenir
ou soutenir
simplement l'énergie
pour que tu fonctionnes
et marches
avec sa liberté
mais pour que
la Bible nous montre clairement
qu'il est en train
de diriger
ce qu'il a créé.
Cela nous a conduit
à une définition
de la doctrine.
Je vous répète
la définition
de la doctrine.
C'est cet exercice
continu
de la puissance divine
par lequel
les créateurs soutiennent
toutes ces créatures
donc il y a
la notion des soutiens
agit
dans tout ce qui se passe
dans les mondes
et dirige
toutes choses
vers leur fin
fixé.
Et donc nous affirmons
qu'il y a
trois aspects
dans la doctrine
de la providence
il y a
l'aspect
des préservations
en Dieu
qui est activement
en train de pourvoir
les mentions
de toutes les sphères
de tout ce qui existe
donc il est en train
de pourvoir
par exemple
les simples mentions
de mon fonctionnement
digestif
ou respiratoire
ou de mon raisonnement
de ma capacité logique
ok
mais il est aussi
en train de pourvoir
les forces
pour que je puisse
travailler
s'aimer
mais il est aussi
en train de pourvoir
la pluie
pour arroser
les terrens
et les fonctionements
de là
pour produire
les fruits
et donc il est en train
de par là
pourvoir aussi
la nourriture
envers ces créatures
dans tous les détails
de la création
Dieu est activement
en train de pourvoir
les mentions
de toutes les choses
ok
les mentions
de l'équilibre
magnétique
interplanétaire
dans les systèmes solaires
et dans tous les univers
c'est Dieu
qui est en train
d'activement
les maintenir
donc il y a cette notion
des mentions
il y a aussi la notion
des gouvernements
donc Dieu
il pourvoir
aux mentions
de toutes les choses
attention
en préservant
la liberté
mais lorsque nous
exerçons la liberté
Dieu est en train
de diriger
même par nos décisions
même par nos actions
même par
les épisodes
cataclysmatiques
cataclysmiques
Dieu est en train
de gouverner
toutes ces choses
des manières
à faire
que tout
vienne à converger
envers son plan parfait
donc c'est la gouvernance
des dieux
et donc par là
il y a aussi
ce qu'on appelle
la concurrence
donc la concurrence
à nouveau
c'est la Bible
qui nous enseigne
et c'est l'expérience
de nous tous
nous savons tous
que nous sommes
quelque part
libres
et là
on n'est pas en train
de parler
du libre arbitre
je ne vais pas revenir
aujourd'hui
sur cette question
sauf si on pose
la question à la fin
on parle de la libre
agence
la capacité
d'arbitrer
parfaitement
on l'a perdu
car on est
corrompu
par les péchés
mais nous avons
un libre choix
dans nos décisions
dans la plupart
de nos décisions
au moins
et dans les quotidiens
on agit
selon ces décisions
on a une conscience
qu'elle a
plus ou moins
cautérisée
on a les inclinations
envers les péchés
mais la réalité
c'est que nous sommes
en train de faire
c'est qu'on a voulu faire
c'est qu'on a décidé
de faire
et à partir de là
on est en train
d'agir
librement
et nous sommes responsables
et la Bible
affirme clairement
dans ce sens là
il n'y a pas
un fatalisme
car Dieu a déterminé
que toutes les choses
vont se passer
comme il a planifié
mais toutes les choses
vont se passer
comme il a planifié
à travers
la libre agence
des agents
responsables
et à travers
toutes les variables
d'un monde
d'un mouvement
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que nous n'avons pas
la capacité
d'harmoniser
ces deux choses
même car Dieu
est en train
de nous révéler
sa souveraineté
d'un point de vue
éternel
quand il parle
de ces décrets éternels
mystérieux
auxquels
personne n'accède
et par exemple
si Dieu
a déterminé
que quelqu'un
serait riche
la règle générale
c'est que cette personne
allait travailler
durement
avec intégrité
qu'elle allait
s'efforcer
pour chercher
à passer
par des bonnes formations
sauf que nous savons
tous
qu'il y a
plein d'autres variables
qui peuvent jouer
dans la vie d'une personne
pour qu'elle
devienne riche
donc Dieu
a plusieurs moyens
de conduire
les choses
à une fin particulière
sauf que
pour chaque vie
particulière
tous ces moyens
qui pour nous
représentaient
des réelles
possibilités
des choix
différents
on a à chaque fois
choisi
parfaitement
en accord
avec ce qui
Dieu avait planifié
et Dieu
est en train
de gouverner
les choses
dans la bonne direction
donc nous
sommes à l'opposé
du fatalisme
nous les réformés
nous les protestants
nous qui sommes
bibliques
pour quelles raisons
car nous cherchons
à faire les choses
notamment
car on sait
que Dieu
a déterminé
que si certaines choses
vont se passer
dans nos vies
ça se passera
à travers aussi
nos choix responsables
voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous donne
plein de conseils
et plein de schémas
voilà pourquoi
proverbes
ce sont des règles générales
des moyens
par lesquels
Dieu a l'habitude
d'agir
et de confirmer
en tant que récompense
ceux qui vont
marcher
par un certain
schéma
et donc
si Dieu
par exemple
a décidé
que mes enfants
seraient sauvés
il a aussi déterminé
que moi
je serais responsable
en tant qu'élève
en tant qu'parent
pour son éducation
il a aussi décrété
que moi
j'allais prier
beaucoup
pour la conversion
de mes enfants
et donc
conscient
du fait
que
Dieu
a ses plans
éternels
je cherche
à marcher
envers les bénédictions
que Dieu a planifiées
pour moi
ou pour l'avancement
de son roi homme
en exerçant
responsablement
les tâches
que j'essaie
que Dieu
utilise
et détermine
pour que
certains
fangs soient
accomplis
donc vous comprenez
la conception
des concurrences
ce que nous faisons
est les moyens
déterminés
par Dieu
comme la cause
secondaire
de son plan
final
ultime
la cause finale
c'est les plannings
et les décrets
des dieux
la cause secondaire
à travers laquelle
les plans des dieux
vont s'accomplir
est la libre agence
des êtres responsables
et donc
tout ce que je viens
de dire jusqu'ici
par rapport
à la définition
de ce qu'il y a
la providence
et de ce qu'elle
va comprendre
dans cette relation
avec la concurrence
nous les trouvons
dans les deux premiers
paragraphes
de la confession
des fois
donc je vais vous lire
et j'espère
que cela puisse
représenter
ce qu'on a vu
jusqu'ici
Dieu
les bons créateurs
de toutes choses
dans sa puissance
et sa sagesse
infinie
soutient
dirige
dispose
et gouverne
toutes les créatures
et toutes les choses
les plus grandes
aux plus petites
par sa très sage
et sainte providence
au fond pour lesquelles
elles ont été créées
il est fait
selon la préscience
sa préscience
infaillible
et les conseils
libres
et immuables
de sa propre volonté
à la louange
de sa sagesse
de sa puissance
de sa justice
de son infinie bonté
et de sa miséricorde
glorieuse
par rapport
à la préscience
et au décret
des dieux
la cause première
toute chose
arrive
immuablement
et infailliblement
de sorte
que rien n'arrive
par hasard
ou en dehors
de sa providence
par la même providence
cependant
Dieu leur ordonne
de se produire
selon la nature
des causes
secondes
que ce soit
nécessairement
librement
ou de façon
contingente
nécessairement
donc quelque part
Dieu a imposé
que ces choses
vont se passer
que ce soit
librement
ou même
de façon
apparemment
aléatoire
et parfois même
contraire
apparemment
à ce que Dieu
vise à produire
donc l'exemple
des frères
de Joseph
qui cherchent
à s'opposer
quelque part
au plan des dieux
car Joseph a eu un rêve
et c'était à travers lui
que toutes les promesses
envers Israël
allaient s'accomplir
et donc
ses frères s'élèvent
en jalousie
contre lui
les frappent
les vent comme esclaves
mais toutes ces choses
qui apparemment
étaient contraires
au plan des dieux
sont en train
de contribuer
de manière encore
plus accélérée
quelque part
pour qu'il
devienne
gouverneur d'Egypte
et préserve son peuple
et donc
de manière extraordinaire
Dieu fait
la concurrence
des choses
envers
ce qu'il a prénoncé
et donc
ces deux paragraphes
résument
cette première partie
de la définition
de la doctrine
et ensuite
on a considéré
les dégrés
ou les aspects
d'exécution
donc on parle
d'une providence générale
c'est le son des dieux
général
et le soutien
des dieux général
et la direction
envers
toutes les choses
qu'il a créées
la providence universelle
c'est les dieux
du macro
et les dieux
du microcosmos
chaque molécule
est en train de dire
amin à sa volonté
tout comme le soleil
et en train de dire
amin à sa volonté
ce qui est intéressant
c'est que la bible
nous enseigne
non seulement
cette providence générale
mais elle parle
d'une providence spéciale
spéciale
quand on pense
aux détails
particuliers
de tous ceux
qui Dieu est en train
de prendre soin
et maintenir
et diriger
que ce soit
dans la nature
en général
que ce soit
envers les êtres
résumants
donc il est engagé
même dans la provision
des pluies
pour les méchants
et pour les bons
il est engagé
même dans les mentions
du fonctionnement
de la raison
de Nabucodonosor
lorsqu'il cherche
à s'opposer à Dieu
et Dieu va suspendre
sa pensée
il va agir
comme un bête
et Dieu va
restaurer cela
et donc
les cœurs des rois
sont dans l'aimant
de Dieu
et il l'incline
comme il veut
la faveur
accordée à Daniel
par son intercession
c'était une faveur
que Dieu a produit
dans les cœurs
de son dirigeant
et donc ici
nous voyons de manière
très claire
les providences spéciales
des dieux
et donc cette providence
spéciale des dieux
s'affiche dans plusieurs sens
nous avons considéré
je pense qu'une dizaine
la dernière fois
je ne vais pas revenir
sur elles toutes
mais ça va
dans toutes les directions
là où on considère
même
les dés
qu'on peut lancer
ok
les sorts se lancent
dans les pans
de la robe
mais du Seigneur
procède toute décision
et donc c'est Dieu
qui est en train
de gouverner
les résultats
des dés qu'on va lancer
il est en train
de diriger
il l'avait décrété
mais pour nous
dans notre perspective
c'est
ce qui est le plus proche
de l'aléatoire
qu'on puisse imaginer
de manière réelle
et donc ici
nous voyons
dès l'importance
des oiseaux
qui tombent par terre
mais particulièrement
pour ceux
qui s'éportent
dans la direction
du peuple
des dieux
donc les succès
ou les échecs
des nations
les rois
ou les empires
la montée
ou la chute
des empires
donc on va
dans tous les sens
et on a considéré
une dizaine
et on a conclu
avec la considération
de ce qu'on appelle
les providences
extraordinaires
ou les miracles
et ici
il y a une distinction
intéressante
entre providences
extraordinaires
et miracles
les providences
extraordinaires
ce sont des choses
qui de manière
très calculée
Dieu peut faire
converger
pour que ça se passe
en faveur de son peuple
donc par exemple
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
lorsque Jésus Christ
arrive à la fin
de son ministère
et proche de la croix
il y a une conspiration
de la part
des pharisiens
des sadduciens
qui voulaient déjà
attraper les crises
ils disent
de manière très express
cherchons
à faire tout cela
avant la Pâque
pour que le peuple
ne soit pas en tumulte
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que leur plan
a été frustré
car le plus
ils ont essayé
de contrôler
cette conspiration
le plus ils ont fait
de manière très aléatoire
que Christ soit crucifié
exactement
à l'heure même
où les agneaux
étaient en train
d'être crucifiés
et donc là
on est devant
ce qu'on appelle
une providence extraordinaire
on pense que tout
est vulnérable
aux agences
des êtres humains
et Dieu est en train
de faire tout converger
à la crucifixion
de Christ
de cette manière
donc des fois
on voit des personnes
qui cherchent
à expliquer
les miracles
de manière scientifique
par Discovery Channel
ou d'autres
et la réalité
c'est que par là
on est en train
de vider
la signification
de miracle
car un miracle
par définition
c'est lorsque
Dieu agit
sans les ressources
naturelles
qui lui-même
a déterminé
pour produire
certaines choses
contrairement
à la direction
de la nature
ou au-dessus
ce sont ça
les définitions
les plus
claires
dans miracle
donc
troisième paragraphe
de la confession
dans sa providence
Dieu normalement
se sert des moyens
!
il est cependant
libre d'agir
sans ses moyens
par-dessus ses moyens
!
ou contre eux
si tel est son plaisir
donc quand est-ce que
Dieu
dans sa parole
a agi
sans ses moyens
donc nous pouvons
penser
par exemple
à la naissance
virginale du Christ
ou sans
les moyens
naturels
des reproductions
Dieu
a formé
les corps
du Christ
dans les ventres
de Marie
nous pouvons
penser que
Dieu
peut travailler
par-dessus
ses moyens
car
même si
Sarah
et Abraham
ont eu
des relations
on savait
qu'elles étaient
stériles
et Dieu
a travaillé
au-dessus
des limitations
naturelles
et c'est de là
et il travaille
parfois contre
si tel est son plaisir
et nous pouvons
penser par exemple
au buisson ardent
qui est enflammé
mais ne se consomme pas
contrairement au feu
ou même
aux trois compagnons
de Daniel
Mezak, Sadra
et Abnego
je ne sais pas
comment vous dites
en français
mais si
qui étaient
dans la fournaise
sans être brûlés
donc on voit
comment Dieu
travaille par exemple
pour ouvrir
la mer rouge
qui devrait plutôt
rester fermé
et donc ce sont
des miracles
et donc
on a conclu
la dernière fois
avec les aspects
difficiles
de la doctrine
de la providence
on a considéré
quelques objections
je vais rajouter
une autre aujourd'hui
et on va continuer
avec d'autres points
la première objection
c'est
Dieu
il est trop grand
et trop tôt puissant
pour être troublé
ou préoccupé
par les détails
insignifiants
de nos petits problèmes
et donc on a vu
que Dieu
est particulièrement
intéressé
pour l'humanité
d'une manière générale
car il l'a créé
à son image
et particulièrement
intéressé
pour chacun
de ses enfants
les chrétiens
adoptés par Christ
et Philippien nous dit
ne vous inquiétez
de rien
mais en toute chose
faites connaître
à Dieu
vos besoins
par des prières
et supplications
avec action des grâces
et Jésus
le Christ lui-même
dans son serment
contre l'inquiétude
l'anxiété
il va présenter
plusieurs raisons
pour qu'on considère
que notre Père Céleste
connaît chacun
de nos besoins
avant même
qu'on les dise
et Christ nous enseignait
qu'il compte
les cheveux de la tête
et chacun
de ses enfants
donc Dieu
est très intéressé
pour chaque détail
de nos vies
et donc dans nos prières
on peut
être sûr
que sa providence
passe par les quotidiens
les pains quotidiens
chaque larme
chaque souffrance
chaque moment
des joies
Dieu est en train
de se réjouir
avec nous
c'est ça que j'essaye
au maximum
d'enseigner à mes enfants
non seulement
des pensées
au moment de souffrance
qu'on va faire recours à Dieu
mais des savoirs
que lorsqu'ils sont en train
de jouer avec leurs jouets
ils peuvent compter
avec la présence des dieux
qui sont en train
de se réjouir avec eux
et pour moi
c'était très intéressant
car quand je me suis converti
moi j'avais
une relation
avec la nature
avec les sports
qui étaient très proches
c'était comme un idole
pour moi
mais la chose
qui m'a plus surpris
après ma conversion
c'est comme si
j'avais senti
que Dieu avait créé
toutes ces bonnes choses
pour moi
pour que je puisse
se réjouir
avec Dieu
c'est comme si tout
brillait
avec la compagnie
des dieux
moi j'ai pas eu
les privilèges
d'avoir mon père
de mon côté
dans mon enfance
mais c'était très intéressant
d'avoir cette pensée
extraordinaire
et c'est ça
que j'essaye de communiquer
à mes enfants
c'est un dieu
qui s'est réjoui
avec nous
lorsqu'on est en train
d'avoir
les moindres joies
dans la vie
donc rien que
de regarder par exemple
je sais pas comment dire
en français
mais c'est un type
des perroquets
de Sud-Amérique
et qu'il a fait
une migration
ici envers la France
et des fois
je les vois
dans ma rue même
et je ne peux pas
n'ai pas connecté
cette réalité
avec les sourires
des dieux envers moi
vous comprenez
ces petits détails
donc c'est un dieu
les dieux de la Providence
qui est très intéressés
aux petits détails
dans nos vies
et donc
les lois de la nature
c'est la deuxième objection
rendent une telle intervention
divine impossible
donc là
ils sont dans un système
fermé
très scientifique
et ils ne veulent pas
croire à aucune chose
que la science
ne puisse pas expliquer
donc ils font plus de confiance
aux lois de la nature
qu'à celui
qui a créé
et qui soutient
cette propre loi
donc cette objection
est complètement réfutée
l'enseignement public
est clair
à plusieurs reprises
Dieu va agir
au-dessus
des lois
qu'il lui-même
a créées
contrairement à elle
dans sa manière
de gouverner
toutes les choses
la plus grande difficulté
comme on a considéré
la dernière fois
si Dieu
ou les dieux
qui gouvernent
et contrôlent
toutes les choses
est un Dieu bon
et sans
comment comprendre
la réalité du péché
ou des injustices
dans les mondes
les actes pécheurs
sont
sous les contredivants
c'est la première partie
de cette réponse
et ils ne se produisent
qu'il est par la permission
des dieux
et selon son descend
l'ultime
donc
on ne veut pas
avoir une attitude lâche
envers la conception
de la permission
car nous ne sommes pas ici
en train d'utiliser
les termes permission
pour essayer d'excuser
Dieu
d'avoir décrété
ces choses
alors s'il avait
le choix
de ne pas permettre
mais il a choisi
de permettre
il est quand même
l'ultime responsable
de l'avoir permis
sauf que
la réalité du fait
que Dieu
agit
par la concurrence
de la responsabilité
des agents libres
ça renvoie
à l'être
humain libre
et responsable
la coupabilité
d'agir
dans la direction
du péché
de décider
pour les péchés
et pour l'injustice
donc c'est clair
que Dieu
dans sa sagesse
sera toujours juste
mais la justice
des dieux
elle n'est pas
nécessairement liée
à la privation
tout simplement
que les injustices
soient commises
ça fait partie
d'avoir créé
l'être humain
dans son état
de pureté
à son image
qu'il ait
à l'origine
le libre arbitre
la capacité
d'arbitrer
sans l'influence
du péché
l'homme n'a pas été
créé à l'origine
avec les péchés
pour l'influencer
dans la direction
du péché
c'est lui
qui a fait les choix
malgré
une
un arbitre
une capacité
d'arbitrer
des jugés
qui étaient purs
à l'origine
et lui
il a fait la décision
de la rébellion
donc l'être humain
à cet égard
est devenu
le seul responsable
pour les péchés
nous sommes en train
de considérer
la perspective
humaine
de la réalité
des libres choix
dans
les décrets
éternels
des dieux
Dieu avait déjà
son plan 1
et par les décrets
du péché
nous comprenons
comment Dieu
va mettre en lumière
encore plus
plusieurs de ses attributs
qu'on ne connaissait pas
à l'intensité
et même pas
connaître tout simplement
l'attribut en soi
si les péchés
n'étaient pas décrétés
n'étaient pas permis
dans ce sens là
pourquoi
car nous comprenons
par les péchés
la taille
de la sainteté
des dieux
donc la justice
va revendiquer
la justice
car tout péché
commis par la responsabilité
humaine
sera puni
mais cela a anticipé
aussi
cette punition
du jugement final
en Jésus Christ
à la croix
donc on a connu
non seulement
le fait que Dieu
aime l'humanité
mais que Dieu
aime tellement
ceux qui vont croire
en Christ
car pour nous justifier
il a dû punir
nos péchés
dans son propre fils
donc ça montre
non seulement
la taille
de la justice
des dieux
qu'on ne connaîtra pas
on ne connaîtra pas
différemment
la taille
de la sainteté
des dieux
car si
nous sommes
mériteurs
d'une punition éternelle
car nous nous sommes
rébellés
contre Dieu lui-même
c'est l'honneur
des dieux
l'autorité des dieux
l'amabilité
des dieux
qui sont affichés
sur le fait
que tout péché
est commis
contre un être
si aimable
et un être
si juste
si souverain
si pur
mérite
une punition éternelle
pourquoi la punition
est éternelle
car elle est
proportionnelle
à la dignité
à l'amabilité
et à la justice
des dieux
et pourquoi
Dieu va
revendiquer
cette justice
de manière ultime
à la croix
pour ceux qui croient
c'est car aussi
dans la punition
éternelle
des réprobres
nous serons
en train de contempler
pour toute l'éternité
combien juste
Dieu est
et nous allons
comprendre par là
davantage
ce qui Christ a de
souffrir à notre place
vous comprenez
et donc
si Dieu a décrété
que ces choses
se passent
on ne peut pas
comprendre
toute la complexité
de comment les péchés
rentrent
dans l'histoire
mais nous savons
très bien
par les versets
et les passages
plus clairs
que Dieu
n'est pas
l'auteur du mal
il ne peut
tenter personne
et c'est
l'être
le responsable
du péché
donc la doctrine
de la concurrence
nous aide
à affirmer
ouvertement
ce que la Bible
affirme ouvertement
c'est que l'homme
est responsable
du péché
et Dieu
est au contrôle
et à un moment donné
il va
revendiquer sa justice
par la punition
des pécheurs
par l'opportunité
de justification
en Christ
pour les croyants
et il va faire
que les péchés
soient convergés
en bonnes choses
donc Dieu
restreint
et contrôle
les péchés
c'est la deuxième partie
de la réponse
et Dieu
renverse
les péchés
pour en tirer
du bien
quels sont les biens
que Dieu va tirer
du péché
j'ai déjà dit
d'un côté
c'est lorsqu'il va
punir
selon ceux
qui méritent
les péchés
de l'autre côté
c'est la manière
dont il va justifier
les pécheurs
en Jésus Christ
mais
c'est particulièrement
en train de renverser
les mâles
en bien
donc Genèse 50
vous avez médité
de faire les mal
contre moi
Dieu l'a changé
en bien
pour accomplir
ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui
pour sauver
la vie
d'un peuple
nombreux
Genèse 50
les cas
de Joseph
Dieu ne cause
jamais les péchés
ni ne l'approuve
et il ne fait
qu'il permettre
les diriger
les restreindre
les limiter
et les renverser
l'homme seul
est responsable
de son péché
Jacques
il nous dit clairement
au chapitre 1
verset 12
heureux l'homme
qui se porte
patiemment
la tentation
car après avoir
été prouvé
il recevra
la couronne
des vies
que les seigneurs
a promise
à ceux
qu'il aime
que personne
lorsqu'il est tenté
ne dise
c'est Dieu
qui me tente
car Dieu
ne peut
être tenté
par les mâles
c'est une question
d'incapacité
ou d'impossibilité
des natures
même
d'être
Dieu ne peut
être tenté
par les mâles
il est
les feux
absolus
de pureté
si vous voulez
c'est la représentation
du soleil
elle-même
et il ne tente
lui-même personne
mais chacun
est tenté
quand il est attiré
et amorcé
par sa propre
convoitise
puis la convoitise
lorsqu'elle est conçue
enfante les péchés
et les péchés
étant consommés
produit
la mort
comment la confession
résume
cette réponse
à la question
du péché
la toute puissance
des dieux
sa sagesse
insondable
et sa bonté
infinie
quatrième paragraphe
se manifeste
dans sa providence
de sorte que
son conseil
détermine
pardon
déterminé
s'étend même
jusqu'à la première
chute
à toutes les autres
actions coupables
des anges
et des hommes
ok
c'est Dieu
qui est en train
même de maintenir
et de pourvoir
les bons fonctionnements
ou même
les mauvais fonctionnements
de la raison
de ces agents libres
qui vont prendre
des décisions
et Dieu
est en train
de préserver
leurs existences
et permettre
qu'ils fassent
leurs décisions
mauvaises
c'était le cas
pour Adam
pour les démons
et c'est là
non en les permettant
seulement
mais il les tient
en bride
selon sa très grande
sagesse
et puissance
les ordonne
et les gouverne
de multiples façons
à ses fins
qui sont très saintes
à la fin
même si temporairement
l'impie
va s'enrichir
et les chrétiens
vont traverser
la souffrance
ou la privation
Dieu sera en train
d'utiliser
la souffrance
et la privation
pour produire
les biens spirituels
chez les chrétiens
l'intimité avec Dieu
des richesses
infiniment supérieures
à ce que
ce monde peut offrir
et il sera en train
de cumuler
les justes jugements
envers l'impie
qui est en train
de s'enrichir
par ses injustices
et un jour
Dieu va revendiquer
selon sa sagesse
sa justice
donc des multiples façons
à ses fins
qui sont très saintes
Dieu revendiquera
sa sainteté
à travers
toutes les étapes
de la vie
cependant
il est fait
de manière
à ce que
les caractères
pécheurs
des actes
viennent seulement
des créatures
et non des dieux
qui est très saint
et très juste
et ne peut
ni être
l'auteur de péché
ni l'approuver
ça
c'est tout simplement
les clairs
enseignements
des écritures
à cet égard
il y en a
plein
des passages bibliques
pour montrer
cette vérité
Dieu est si pur
des dieux
qui ne peut même
pas contempler
les mâles
donc nous voyons
de manière très claire
qu'il tient
coupable
ceux qui sont
les responsables
directs de péché
paragraphe 5
dans sa très grande
sagesse
sa justice
et sa grâce
Dieu souvent
expose pour un temps
ses propres enfants
à des multiples tentations
et aux corruptions
de leur propre cœur
afin de les châtier
pour leur péché antérieur
ou pour leur révéler
la force cachée
de la corruption
et de la tromperie
de leur cœur
afin qu'ils en soient
humiliés
son but est
de les amener
à une dépendance
plus étroite
et constante
de lui
et de son appui
il les rend
plus vigilants
face aux toutes
occasions futures
des péchés
et pour d'autres
objectifs justes
et sans
ainsi
tous ceux qui
arrivent
à ses élus
leur arrivent
selon son descent
pour sa gloire
et leur bien
on va revenir
sur ces points
bientôt
paragraphe 6
quant à ces personnes
méchantes
et en piquet
Dieu
les justes
et juges
aveugles
et endourcies
pour leur péché
antérieur
non seulement
il leur refuse
sa grâce
par laquelle
elles auraient pu
avoir l'intelligence
éclairée
et les cœurs
travaillés
mais parfois
il leur reprend
les dons
qu'elles avaient
et les livre
à des réalités
qui leur corruption
transforme en occasion
des péchés
de plus
ils les abandonnent
à leurs propres convoitises
aux tentations du monde
et au pouvoir de Satan
en vertu
des quoi
elles s'endourcissent
elles-mêmes
par les moyens
par les mêmes moyens
dont Dieu
s'essert
pour en assouplir
d'autres
ici c'est très intéressant
donc ici
c'est la reconnaissance
que l'une des manières
de Dieu
de traiter
les péchés
qu'il a permis
que ces personnes
se commettent
c'est
de freiner
quelque part
sa grâce
c'est
d'apporter
certaines punitions
temporelles
mais selon
sa sagesse
des fois
il y a
certaines personnes
qui ont l'apparence
de tout simplement
prospérer dans la vie
mais Dieu
réserve
la punition éternelle
de leurs âmes
pour les jugements futurs
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que dans
ces plans éternels
des dieux
la Bible est très claire
pour démontrer
que l'homme
et toute l'humanité
est responsable
de son propre péché
donc on va revenir
à cette question difficile
nous savons très bien
que sans l'évangile
personne ne peut se convertir
ça c'est un point clair
pour nous tous
par contre
pour que nous soyons
inexcusables
devant Dieu
nous n'avons pas besoin
de l'évangile
donc la question
la fameuse question
par rapport
aux tribus
indigènes
qui n'ont jamais
connu l'évangile
est-ce que c'est juste
qu'ils soient dirigés
vers l'enfer
la réponse biblique
elle est très claire
ayant la connaissance
des dieux
ils n'ont pas
adoré comme dieux
rendu grâce à dieux
ils sont inexcusables
car les évidences
des dieux
sont claires
et accessibles
à toute l'humanité
la bonté des dieux
sa toute puissance
roman chapitre 1
du chapitre 1
à 3
c'est dieux
qui resserre
toute l'humanité
dans la condamnation
car nous sommes
responsables
de notre ingratitude
et de notre rébellion
contre dieux
ok
et donc
sur quelle base
toute l'humanité
est condamnée
sur la base
de la rébellion
de notre race
et des péchés
individuels
commis
par chacun d'entre nous
malgré les évidences
de la bonté
des dieux
la bible utilise
un terme
qui est la prédestination
pour parler
de ceux
qui dieux a élus
et qu'à un moment
dans la vie
comme on l'a lu
en éphésiens chapitre 1
au début
dieux interviendra
dans nos vies
pour changer
la nature humaine
par sa grâce
afin qu'on puisse
utiliser notre volonté
dans la direction
des dieux
mais lorsque nous tous
sommes livrés
à notre propre volonté
sans que dieux
interviennent
dans nos vies
nous sommes en train
de nous diriger
volontairement
vers la rébellion
et envers l'enfer
mériteur de l'enfer
qui nous sommes
et donc la réalité
c'est que
selon
notre propre manière
d'agir
et la bible est très claire
à cet égard
lorsque la bible
va considérer
par la perspective
divine
la manière
dont nous sommes
en train d'endourcir
nos cœurs
parfois
Dieu va décrire
par les décrets
de Dieu
qui
Dieu
par exemple
a endourci
les cœurs
des pharaons
mais les cœurs
qui étaient
endourcis
la bible dit
cinq fois
Dieu a endourci
les cœurs
des pharaons
pour accomplir
ses plans
en faveur
d'Israël
mais cinq fois
la bible dit
que pharaon
a endourci
son propre cœur
c'est-à-dire
malgré
la punition
apportée par Dieu
quelqu'un dit ça
les mêmes soleils
qui adoucit
la cire
endourcit
l'argile
et donc
un cœur
rébelle
déviant
devant les catastrophes
les difficultés
les souffrances
chaque fois
puissent faire
un bien contre Dieu
mais certains
qui ont traversé
les mêmes souffrances
sont venus
plutôt vers Dieu
pour trouver
les secours
et donc
prédestination
c'est car
sans que Dieu
intervienne
personne ne sera
sauvé
personne ne va
vouloir aller
dans la direction
des dieux
à causer
sa corruption
par contre
la Bible
quand elle parle
de la préordination
Romain chapitre 9
des vases
des colères
préparés en avance
pour la perdition
pour que Dieu
manifeste
la puissance
de sa colère
et donc là
Dieu est en train
de parler
de ces personnes
qui volontairement
sont rebelles
et Dieu va faire
un osage
pour en elles
afficher
sa justice
suprême
qui rend gloire
à son
car qui peut
adorer
un juge
qui sans avoir
été justifié
et sans avoir
été puni
va
libérer
ou déclarer
comme juste
celui
qui était
par exemple
un pédophile
impénitent
non-répentant
que tous
applaudissent
ma miséricorde
sans qu'il traverse
aucune punition
ou sans qu'il aille
même un représentant
légal
qui souffre
à sa part
comme Christ
est pour nous
et donc Dieu
il va
envers les impénitents
manifester
la gloire
de sa juste
colère
et donc
dans la temporalité
nous sommes
susceptibles
à un Dieu
qui fait
plusieurs usages
différents
de plusieurs moyens
pour traiter
les impis
les impénitents
les pécheurs
mais c'est intéressant
car ça évoque
aussi
cet autre aspect
des difficultés
qui a la souffrance
des sangs
et moi
pour parler
de manière
très résumée
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
dans les paragraphes
ici
devant nos yeux
car c'est une question
pour les chrétiens
si Jésus-Christ
il a déjà souffert
totalement
ce que j'ai mérité
pourquoi
dois-je encore
traverser
les souffrances
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
nous sommes dans
un monde des chutes
où les restes
des péchés
sont encore là
et Dieu
il va continuer
de travailler
dans nos vies
afin que nous soyons
les plus purifiés
qui est possible
et que nous soyons
les plus efficaces
qui est possible
dans la promotion
des dieux
encore dans cette vie
tout nous est assuré
nous pouvons grandir
dans la connaissance
expérimentale du Christ
par la conformité
dans ses souffrances
comme Paul va le dire
dans sa parole
en collantien
nous pouvons grandir
pour devenir
des plus en plus
participants
de la nature divine
par les souffrances
par les expériences
qu'on traverse
et donc toutes les choses
concourent à notre bien
donc Dieu
travaille
de manière très particulière
avec chacun d'entre nous
des fois nous sommes
très conscients
de ce que Dieu
vise à traiter avec nous
lorsqu'on traverse
un moment difficile
mais des fois
les choses sont
tellement imprévisibles
comme par exemple
est-ce que David
serait dès le départ
lorsqu'il était
un peu mis à l'écart
comme les plus jeunes
dans sa famille
et qu'il devait travailler
en prenant soin
des brébis
et qu'il devrait
s'ébattre
pour protéger
les brébis
contre
un lion
un ours
et que David
en s'ébattant
contre un lion
un ours
sans que personne
ne les voit
apprenne quelque chose
avec Dieu
et qu'en ayant
ce temps
et cette relation
un peu plus calme
avec les animaux
il puisse
développer
ses talents musicaux
et qu'il puisse
lire la Bible
et qu'il la médite
jour et nuit
et que tout cela
serait en train
de jouer
pour qu'un jour
il soit
les grands rois d'Israël
celui qui allait
faire la défaite
du géant
Goliath
comment
pourrait David
s'il était
en train de se plaindre
pendant son parcours
mes frères
ils ont
des professions
plus considérées
un traitement
plus privilégié
à la maison
lui
n'était même
pas considéré
lorsque Samuel
est venu visiter
pour Wanderrois
l'an des enfants
des Gécès
Joseph
est-ce que Joseph
savait
bien sûr
quelque part lié
à son rêve
mais encore
mystérieux
les rêves
qu'il a eus
mais
comment il pourrait
considérer
que par l'administration
d'une prison
où étant
l'esclave
des potifards
en apprenant
à prendre soin
d'une maison
il serait en train
de prendre soin
de toute
l'empire
de l'Egypte
les plus importants
de l'époque
et donc
il y a
des choses
qu'on souffre
sans comprendre
pourquoi
et c'est
bien bien
très tard
qu'on va comprendre
et il y a
des choses
qu'on souffre
car Dieu
est en train
de corriger
des choses
qu'on est
plutôt conscient
qu'on doit corriger
l'intérêt
des dieux
c'est tout simplement
de faire progresser
en piété
en s'entêté
et surtout
en intimité
avec Christ
et donc
la souffrance
des sang
elle fait partie
de cette grande
sagesse
et justice
de la part
des dieux
et on finit
avec les paragraphes
à propos
des vérités
les plus
réconfortantes
à propos
de cette doctrine
de même que
la providence
des dieux
c'est en général
à toutes les créatures
elle prend soin
de l'église
des dieux
de manière
très spéciale
et ordonne
toutes choses
pour son bien
concourent au bien
de ceux
qui aiment Dieu
donc ça
c'est l'une
des affirmations
les plus réconfortantes
et même
des fois
très élevées
pour qu'on puisse
oser la proclamer
mais c'est comme si
tout l'univers
et tous les êtres
humains
non chrétiens
soient comme
des figurants
dans la conduction
de l'histoire
de l'humanité
les plans
finales
des dieux
les plans
initials
des dieux
dès le départ
c'était
attention
à ce que je vais vous dire
des formes
en peuple
pour soi
mais pas tout simplement
en peuple pour soi
comme Adam et Ève
dans les sanctuaires
originales
à l'Édant
qui pourraient
connaître déjà
beaucoup
à propos de dieux
mais
un plan
dans l'histoire
où tout pourrait
servir à maximiser
la connaissance
du peuple
des dieux
de la gloire
infinie
des dieux
lui-même
si les péchés
n'étaient pas rentrés
dans l'humanité
si la punition
des pécheurs
pour toute l'éternité
n'était pas
une réalité présente
qu'on va faire face
on ne sera pas
exposé
à cette manière
de Dieu
de gouverner
toutes les choses
et afficher
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
la gloire
de sa sagesse
de sa bonté
l'intensité
de son amour
pour nous
pour son peuple
car Dieu
a tant aimé
les mondes
qu'il a donné
son fils unique
si les péchés
n'étaient pas là
on ne connaissait pas
un Dieu
qui a tant aimé
les mondes
il y a plein d'aspects
très mystérieux
à cet égard
heureusement
on ne connait pas
tous les élus
on doit proclamer
la vérité à tous
mais la réalité
c'est que quelque part
tout est en train
de servir
de manière
très périphérique
la planète
est en train
de tourner
autour du soleil
aujourd'hui
à cause des élus
à cause de l'église
toutes les persécutions
que l'église a subies
pendant toute l'histoire
de l'humanité
toutes les hérésies
qui ont été élevées
contre l'église
et que l'église
a dû se battre
pour purifier
pour mieux comprendre
toutes les souffrances
de chacun des saints
sont en train
de converger
envers les biens
de l'église
pour que l'église
connaisse mieux
les christs
pour que l'église
expérimente plus les christs
puisse afficher
plus les christs
l'ensemble de la providence
divines
est en faveur de la providence
en faveur du peuple
de Dieu
phrase de Lloyd-Jones
Dieu en dernière
à l'église
oriente toutes les choses
pour les biens
de ses enfants
et que tous les restes
est d'une certaine manière
orienté
ou gouverné
pour leurs bénéfices
voilà pourquoi
l'anxiété
est l'une des choses
les plus contradictoires
à la foi chrétienne
Dieu est en train
de gouverner
toutes les choses
en faveur de son peuple
nous devons
je vous rappelle
être très
prudents
lorsqu'on essaye
de lire un épisode
de nos vies
et d'interpréter
qu'il s'est
en faveur de nous
donc même les chrétiens
certains courants chrétiens
lorsqu'ils ont vu
Staline
ont dit des phrases
très préoccupantes
comme s'il était
en dirigeant
divinement dessiné
la même chose
a été dite
par l'église
à l'époque
de Hitler
à cause de l'immoralité
qui était présente
dans la société
quelqu'un qui monte
avec une apparence
un peu assez légaliste
très moraliste
il y a eu aussi
ici en France
à Dunkerque
un épisode
pendant
je pense que c'était
la première guerre
comme si
une nouée
une providence
extraordinaire
a facilité
la fuite
et là
l'avancée allemande
avait environ
300 000 soldats
contre les britanniques
et les français
et une espèce
de
délivrance inattendue
facilitée
par une mer
exceptionnellement calme
et un brouillard
providentiel
qui limita
la visibilité
des avions allemands
et plusieurs
ont interprété
cela
comme la providence
spéciale des lieux
c'est une possibilité
nous nous avons
au niveau personnel
plein de choses
je me rappelle
d'un ami à moi
que
pour lui
il était en train de faire
un test
pour lequel il n'avait pas
étudié
et
le professeur a changé
la personne la plus
intelligente
il l'a placé à son côté
donc il a pu voir
toutes les choses
et lui il a dit
c'est la providence
et nous on a dit
elle n'est pas bonne
votre orgueil
n'est pas bon
à cet égard
c'est un triste témoin
c'est pas un témoin
et donc c'est clair
qu'on doit faire attention
à ça
mais la réalité
c'est que la doctrine
de la providence
est biblique
est claire
elle tourne autour
surtout
du bien de l'église
mais ce qui représente
les plus grands
du chrétien
dans cette gouvernance
divine
c'est de savoir
remarquer
que notre plus grande
bénédiction
c'est la révélation
des dieux glorieux
en Jésus Christ
et que la providence
est centrée sur Christ
dans le sens où
lui
il est
celui qui soutient
toutes les choses
par sa parole puissante
donc il est
l'agent direct
de la providence
et du maintien
de toutes les choses
les Christ
qui est à notre tête
qui est à notre sauveur
qui est à notre seigneur
qui est à notre époux
c'est lui
qui a toutes ses affections
envers nous
c'est lui
qui a promis
qu'il avait
toute l'autorité
et toute la gouvernance
de tous les détails
de l'univers
et qu'il allait les faire
en faveur de son église
c'est à dire
nous pouvons aller partir
proclamer avec toute l'assurance
au monde
que rien ne va jamais
manquer à l'église
c'est les gouverneurs
de toute la providence
nous ne pouvons
dans aucun cas
douter
de sa provision
et quand on pense
à sa provision
c'est même pas
qu'elle est bien matériel
mais tous les miracles
qu'il peut opérer
pour ouvrir les fronts
à l'avancement
de l'évangile
il est celui
qui soutient
par sa parole puissante
même les battements
de coeur
du persécuteur
qui s'élève
contre son peuple
et donc
le seigneur Jésus
il est celui
en qui toutes les choses
ou de qui
toutes les choses
dépendent
c'est lui
qui est en train
de soutenir
chaque détail
étant les reflets
de sa gloire
et l'emprunte
de sa personne
et soutenant
toutes choses
par sa parole puissante
a fait la purification
des péchés
et s'est assis
à la droite de Dieu
dans la majesté divine
dans les lieux très hauts
qu'est-ce que
les textes veulent dire
par là
non seulement
il est celui
qui est propriétaire
et gouverneur
et pourvoyeur
de toutes les choses
mais c'est celui
qui a fait
une purification
et s'est assis
à la droite
de la majesté divine
c'est-à-dire
notre intercesseur
qui a toute la puissance
nous pouvons
nous retrouver en lui
avec tous les droits
au monde
de solliciter
toutes les bénédictions
qu'il aurait pour nous
car en ayant fait
toute la purification
il n'y a aucune résistance
de la part du Père
de nous offrir
ce qu'on aurait pu
demander à Christ
le seul critère
c'est que
c'est que nous demandons
soit en accord
avec sa volonté
envers nous
en accord
avec l'avancement
de son royaume
vous comprenez ?
en accord
à notre bien suprême
grandir en connaissance
de Christ
et en conformité
avec son caractère
donc c'est lui
qui est
les pourvoyeurs
les mainteneurs
les dirigeants
du coursus
de l'histoire
je vais bâtir
mon église
personne ne peut empêcher
mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que Christ
n'est pas tout simplement
comme si on pourrait dire
que ça c'est simple
mais c'est glorieux
car il est
celui qui pourvoit
toutes les choses
et qui maintient
dans les macros
mais particulièrement
il est appelé
la tête de l'église
c'est lui qui nourrit
l'église
qui prend son église
qui purifie l'église
toutes les provisions
particulières à l'église
ça vient directement
du Christ
mais c'est intéressant aussi
car
il n'est pas seulement
les responsables
primaires
et ultimes
et directs
de tous les maintiens
qu'on puisse imaginer
mais il est lui-même
celui à qui on fait référence
quand on dit
Je vais agir
il est la provision
suprême des dieux
en lui
nous avons
toutes les demandes
humaines satisfaites
et les principales
des demandes
humaines satisfaites
donc notre plus grand
problème c'était
notre condamnation
à cause du péché
et lorsqu'Abraham
vient avec son enfant
et qu'il ne voit pas
qu'est-ce qu'il va présenter
comme sacrifice à Dieu
lorsqu'Isaac
pose la question
il dit
les seigneurs
pourvoient
Je vais
j'irai
les dieux
de la provision
c'est-à-dire
Dieu a pourvu
Christ lui-même
pour être celui
qui fait la réconciliation
entre Dieu et homme
il est la provision
suprême
en ayant Christ
nous n'avons
plus aucun besoin
d'aucune autre chose
c'est lorsque
l'été l'élimine des dieux
il a donné
son fils
quel est tout
quel est max
ne nous donnerait-il pas
avec lui
toutes les autres choses
un filement inférieur
et donc Christ
il est le responsable
direct de toute la provision
Christ
il est la provision suprême
qu'on pourrait demander
et souplir à Dieu
donc c'est à nous
de chérir
les Christ
de la providence
et la providence
du Christ
pour toujours
Amen